ladies and gentlemen it's been a long
time coming but welcome to the very
first episode of the official wild ride
podcast with steve-o this is my co-host
Scott Randolph how's it going you may
know him as Scott Randolph international
star if you've paid really close
attention over the years you know that
he started out as my professional [ __ ]
blocker shortly after I got out of sex
addict rehab I brought him on the road
to help me not get my dick sucked all
the time and she did a really good job
he went on to become my tour manager my
co-producer my opener on tour my
business partner dared my god my best
friend loved this guy
yeah so that's why Scott is gonna be on
every episode of this podcast at least I
damn well wish you will you know who
else is on this first episode [ __ ]
Tony Hawk the biggest icon legend
ambassador of the skateboarding world
and Tony Hawk - video game mogul dared
Tony Hawk's epic he's also a close
friend and a dear friend of the Jackass
family and boy did we get into some wild
stuff this legitimately is a wild ride
so strap on your seatbelts and ladies
and gentlemen Tony Hawk hey what's up
okay let me just start by saying thank
you so much for this I haven't missed
her and hey dude will you do me a favor
hey dude will you do me a favor how many
times and over the whole course of you
know particularly with jackass from the
beginning even before jackass with Big
Brother like you've always like obliged
every absurd favor and it's so so
generous oh it's my pleasure
well it's it's just fun to be connected
with someone so creative and and so much
it's so many fun opportunities well
thank you man and you you've returned
the favor of many times yourself
especially by doing Saturday's birdhouse
video that was that was fun man that was
acting Mike are those fun yeah
Minnie we didn't - Minnie but and David
kept bailing right and so we had to do
it like so basically you and I drove
through I mean it was kind of your stunt
it was totally my study and I had
reached out to you this was where I
jumped off a port-a-potty and you were
there and I shattered my ankle I mean I
had 11 screws in my ankle it was uh as
far as like surgery and screws it was
the worst injury I've ever had which is
fitting because I was there for your
worst injury you ever had
oh yeah that's right Wow I did yeah I
did the loop for wild boys and came
crashing down and broke my pelvis my
thumb cracked my skull that was like a
heavy concussion huh uh yeah yeah that
was that one was pretty heavy I I don't
I woke up I mean you know when you get
concussed there's a moment when you
remember coming to truly know you're
talking and whatever but right my god it
was so it was so upsetting I remember
you they were loading her onto a
stretcher and and you were saying like
don't let my kids see this something
like that really you remember saying
that
I think that's around the time I started
coming to yeah because I remembered the
stretcher I think that what woke me up
was the pain of getting on the stretcher
and I was like something's wrong with my
hip that's the first thing I said and I
remember the guy looked at me he said
bollocks right like you're it's okay did
they show that on Wildboyz the - so they
saved all the footage and then later on
MTV had their show about injuries scars
yeah and then they reached out to
Jermaine and said hey can we get this
footage and Jermaine reached out to me
and he said I just want to make sure
you're cool with this because they're
asking me and that's where it was I mean
this was this was like a really
sensitive and and heavy thing because
Tony Hawk like has always been the
ambassador of skateboarding and really
like you know representing like safety
you know like not on ones salient but
but for you to be not wearing a helmet
was was it was a big deal and the whole
idea what the wild boys doing the loop
was oh
we got a heavier than this chimpanzees
suit Tony you know you gotta be wearing
a chimpanzees suit he can't really put a
helmet into the yeah but that was so
there's a few things with that I mean if
you want to get into the weeds on it Bob
and I were doing this doubles routine
Bob Burnquist and that was a jam to so
well this you were shooting literally
three days after we ended about a
six-week run of dollars we just flown
home from Florida right the tour was
over we had been doing my loop every
night on the tour so for 30 shows doing
right right but now we're at Bob
Burnquist house and rest is a loop that
was made out of wood but but there's the
things we Bob and I didn't intend to do
that
we just did our doubles routine right
and that we had we knew from Huck Jim
and like I said hey monkey loop and I
remember thinking like maybe that's a
good idea but but we had we were so
caught i was so cocky about the loop
that we had been doing that i was like
we got this and then I remember Bob went
down first and he bailed and I really
should have saw that as a warning sign
Bob on his own loop right it was like
waterlogged made out of wood like you
guys I was trash it was that was the
problem the problem was like we couldn't
get the right amount of speed and then
when on my second attempt I did mistake
number one which is pump through the
transition because I was trying to I was
trying to compensate for lack of speed
and that's like the first thing you tell
anyone's gonna do loop not through the
transition and Here I am like then I
just did it and I remember like oh
whoops yeah and then you don't remember
anything else until you came to yeah
till they were loading me in the
ambulance yep I mean like he okay Tony
came out of the loop at midnight like on
like a sideways corkscrew kind of a
thing and like I remember it like
midnight to to like six you know like
just vertical drop down and like landed
on the flat there
I remember it looking more like your
head on the flat then then your hip but
I think it was all at once yeah it was
the most it was the most beautiful
brutal and you were there I was there
yeah I was in a footage and I remember
thinking like they had two girls in
bikinis standing right there
like I landed right in front of that ha
ha and then him and Pontius and all you
hear is Tremaine gone medic yes yes that
was that that was the worst I mean who
has more broken bones between two of you
guys he does absolutely that was I've
only broken one other bone since then
besides that one people ask me a lot if
they are how many bones I've broken and
the answer is always it depends if you
count teeth counting teeth
Wow what's that about concussions
there's only one right now this was a
conversation with you Tony that I'll
never forget and it was the day when I
shattered my ankle jumping off the porta
potty which was such an honor man to
have you standing there while I'm
jumping off in an eight-foot port aliza
the car through it I mean if you're
gonna shatter your ankle that's a pretty
cool way to do it wonder who was more at
risk was Danny in that beat-up car while
trying to they were there yeah I kept
trying to like hold the windshield up in
place and then by force
yeah right and then on top of that like
there was a porta potti I was just like
you know a Mach wouldn't out house made
out of all these like I mean like yes
like sticks potential spirits fears but
it was that morning and we're you know
get everything set up there you know
bring in a truck in with the
porta-potties and we're just hanging out
and I forget how I came up but we got
onto the the topic of concussions
you know CTE jobs like you know that's
been in the news so much and you told me
I'll never forget this he said I found
out that there's a test that you can get
and if the test determines whether you
have a certain gene
which makes he predisposed for
Alzheimer's and I think you said that if
the if you do have the gene then what
that means is that your brain doesn't
like regenerate it doesn't heal a
certain way and that makes you more
susceptible to see CTE and you said I
got the test and I don't have the gene
so I'm like yeah that's great and
remember to think I chewed on that for a
while and then I thought because I was
wondering should I get this test right
and then I thought well what happens if
what happens if you get the test in and
you do have the gene you know like and
you're in your change your lifestyle
yeah but you're in your 40s you've been
hitting your head for decades yeah
you're right and and I've actually
learned a bit since then through working
with Steph and Lauren Rogen for hilarity
for charity because they do like there
they go deep into being proactive and
preventative and there are measures you
can take to be preventative about it
even if you have the gene even if you've
had concussions so thank you think
saunas are good sleeps good yeah I know
what you diet and and I I took the test
and I don't have the gene because
worried about it's my grandfather
he died of Alzheimer's he got it at like
58 he's like really young and they said
just because you don't have the gene
it's I'm still at a nine percent risk
sure but but i think that i think that
the concussions can exasperate all that
or speed it up for sure the crazy thing
is when we did that brain test my
brain's older than hisses and he's had
more concussions he's hit his head every
night and so it's just like it's one of
those things were yeah we went for a
brain scan to determine how much trauma
how much stuff there's but like yeah I
just this is I'm so bad when when people
have like tragic stuff and I don't know
what to say but like for to have
Alzheimer's come up and and you just
lost your mom I'm just like bad at this
and the only reason I even want to say
like hey I'm really sorry that
yeah that that happened is because I'm
so close to with my mom she survived an
aneurysm and she really had a like a
tough go for the last five years and I
know it was just you know to to just
know you and and how tough that was like
man yeah it was the hardest thing was
how in and beginning how slowly it came
on but there were certain things you'd
notice and then in the last year too how
quickly it was just like she was gone
she couldn't talk anymore had no signs
of recognition that's the hardest thing
is when you know it's like her body her
her mind betrays her body her body
betrays her mind where her body just
stays alive yeah and and it's just
really an odd scenario where you see
this person they have no idea where they
are who they are who you are and their
body just continues to you know their
heart keeps beating and it's just that
was the hardest part was like seeing her
slip away mentally and then feeling
obligated to go visit her obviously but
but there's no there's nothing there no
one you know I don't know what either
one of us getting out of it except for
the fact that we have to try and so I
kind of resigned to that it was like I
gotta keep going to see her and try to
connect did she ever notice you split
seconds of it hey because I remember
when I went to go visit my grandpa in
the in the Alzheimer's home he he would
just be he couldn't verbalize anything
yeah but then maybe once a week he would
kind of like look at me and mumble
something that didn't make sense but
like laugh and like ya know moments got
less and less yeah so I would say in the
last six months of her life there was
none of that
yeah in had not to bring it up but what
were like the first signs that you saw
they were kind of like like putting the
keys in the oven or so just forgot she
just food to forget things that we had
just talked about or yes went over and
her driving was got frightening and so
we had to take her license away but then
but then she got a boyfriend
who was her age who didn't have
Alzheimer's but was the sketchiest
driver in the world that's me and then
we had to just start providing rights
for her yeah you know this is before her
and whatnot but it was more that we had
to figure out okay if mom's didn't go
somewhere we cannot have our driver
because he's putting everyone at risk so
I get this sense because we were driving
down Paul here he's our editor
extraordinary we call him El Chapo and
Paul had this this he's like you know
man it's crazy how Tony Hawk has been so
famous such an icon for so long but it
just always seemed that he's been very
level-headed always has his head screwed
on at no point does it ever seem like he
went off the rails like Fame got to him
or anything crazy stuff like that and I
think that's a really accurate thing to
point out and you know I think that that
you know like I think it's safe to say
that that your relationship with your
mom and with your dad is you know and
then and then beyond that with Stacy
Peralta that those are the three main
you know that's yes I'm sure they're
definitely major figures that have a lot
of influence on me in my life I think I
I definitely had my moments of dabbling
in fame where it's like oh my god you
gotta give us an example but not before
I tell the listeners who the first
sponsor is to get behind this podcast
I'm so grateful for post mates just
hooking ups up and our listeners because
this podcast hasn't even gone out yet so
let me tell you how much I love post
mates particularly I will never forget
when we were filming titty trickshots
bouncing this rubber ball into this
girl's obnoxiously large fake boobs
I thought dude I want this girl to be
naked in the bathtub and us bounce so we
need bubble bath and that was when I
thought Deardon post mates get me bubble
bath
and posts maids got bubble bath to us so
fast of course the girl didn't get in
the bathtub and who cares and I probably
shouldn't even tell that story anymore
because now I'm engaged but it's a fond
memory of post mates and they are giving
away $100 in free delivery to everybody
who downloads the app signs up with the
promo code wild ride and uses it in the
first 7 days you get $100 and free
deliveries if you use the promo code
wild ride and I'm just so stoked on post
mates for back in this podcast before I
even started thank you post mate and now
Tony Hawk let's get back into it yeah
dude you got invited to this event you
got invited to this something like that
well that was actually accidental but
I'm talking about like I'm moral in the
sort of mid 2000 range okay when things
were you know our video game was was
hitting and and there were just all
these opportunities and I thought like
oh this is the life I'm supposed to lead
I'm supposed to be a you know this sort
of celebrity and and then I started
going and I realized it was pretty empty
and I think that was probably my saving
grace was that I did get a taste of that
and I was like I don't what am I doing
here
I don't and I but I always had that
sense of not belonging here I'll just
pull this off there you go yeah I always
had the sense of not belonging and and
that came from being a skater and I came
from being a skater in the era of
skating not being cool oh dude I was I
was right in it man so but but it's
still like even so you know fast forward
all that stuff um to literally two days
ago I was at the Oscars still just
feeling so out of place like what am i
doing I didn't watch it but um but my
girl she came home from her like girls
party to watch which they do every year
and she was like dude Tony Hawk was
there and I was like at first I was like
jealous because I've never
but I I remember you posting about the
the documentary about the Soria made
sense to me and they won that they won
yeah whether than what they won the
documentary category they won the short
documentary category uh-huh that's great
so it's called it's called learning to
skateboard in a war zone if you're a
girl and it's about skater Stan project
in Afghanistan and how that came to be
it was the this obviously they worked on
the documentary for a few years and then
they contacted me because I'm a board
member and they said hey we want to have
a screening in LA we're trying to raise
awareness
maybe submit it for Oscar and this is
only about six months ago so I went
tried to do my best to get people there
raise awareness and did a little speech
before I because I had visited the skate
of Stan projects and and then next thing
you know they're they're nominated and
then they said and and I remember this
is how this all happened Holly from
SCADA Stan you started the project he's
like we got a nomination and then I just
wrote back to him like cool see you at
the Oscars as a joke right right and
then he's like yeah I'm trying to get a
ticket and then about a week later he's
like I got my ticket I'll see you there
I'm like Oliver I don't have an Oscar no
no no so so what happened was then I
said Oliver I don't have a ticket I was
just kidding he's like oh I'll try to
get your ticket so then he goes back in
about a week later and this is just this
is like a week before it's even
happening and he says I got your ticket
I was like that's crazy laughs right now
but then I said well what about can my
wife go he's like I could barely get you
a ticket like I don't that's not
possible then two days before the Oscars
I got a call from the Academy and they
said hey would you like you and your
wife like to sit in the orchestra
section then now I don't know anything
I assume that to dub section to be in
yeah I'm like like pianos right here
Josh got all the Casper 19:17 over here
is parasite next okay
Laura Dern who else Keanu is just rad
he's pretty rad yeah afterwards then I
get the truth and what happened was two
of the main producers of parasite got
stuck in China because of the corona
virus that's great I mean dude I mean I
love how much humility Tony has because
it's like if you look at it from the
perspective of like the Oscars and here
you've got this this documentary about
skateboarding like what an opportunity
to have Tony Hawk sit there and be
affiliated with that film you know I
would feel weird if I had really no
relation to it that would be awkward for
me right because then it would just be
like oh you it'd be more for show and
more to try to like draw attention to
myself but I did have a hand in getting
it there so I felt good about that sure
I mean are you kidding me a documentary
about skateboarding yeah that's crazy
yeah he's in the Oscars haven't seen him
and like I've I don't think I'll ever
set foot on an Oscars red carpet or have
anything to do with any nominations but
[Laughter]
it was a bad grandpa was a jackass no
man they got nominated for I think best
makeup maybe oh really
sense yeah make sense and they didn't
win it I don't think but um but yeah I
always had it in my mind that like if I
did win an Oscar I'd be the first person
on the stage to drop his drawers and
shove it up my butt but part of me has
this thing like you know they like all
of my my comedy and stuff like is is now
like sort of tracking my experience in
life and thus like Herriman my forty's
having a midlife crisis and
as I look towards putting together my
next show it's like oh now I gotta like
actually go to like the doctor for like
the colonoscopy kind of things that we
do and you know when when we get old and
I you know instead of voluntarily
shoving things up your eyes yeah right
and so it did for me there's so much
comedy there because like you know guys
can get in their 40s and then now
they've got to go to the doctor and get
like a finger up there but like you know
no guy wants that and then I'm gonna be
the only dude to ask the doctor like hey
like like how much can I fit up there
like like are we talking an Oscar
because I'll settle for going over to
somebody's place who has won an Oscar
like Juicy J from three 6 mafia I think
I got a fighting chance I'm letting him
like I get him to let me borrow his
Oscar over here the talk is of the
Academy Awards it's straight to stick in
the Oscar we didn't even really have a
segue to that it was just like oh yeah
that's what I want to do with one yeah I
mean you've been wanting to do that for
a while and you did do that on Hollywood
Boulevard I did it with like one of the
toy with hey can you open up the door
just for a smear yeah they have like the
the souvenir store where you buy a
little of the toy plastic Oscar yeah I
did try it
and I'd like I wasn't getting any of
more past the head those children's are
tough and that was like a miniature one
the rule of that's why I got asked the
doctor at the colonoscopy like it like
how much training like how much like can
how much training like a bringing you
know it's gonna go like I'm gonna be
like how much is it really dangerous are
there concerns for me if I'm gonna work
out and stretch to try to fit more and
the doctor is probably gonna be like
you're out of your mind and so I'll go
get a second opinion from like a gay
porn guy
which is really funny really mapped this
out yeah this is what I don't know about
this and so he's just doing all this the
next tour after this one I'm thinking
it's called steve-o's gone too far tour
and like to try and prolapse you but and
and you know if you start like what
would be a process for this like where
were you what I'm doing I think we all
know where it comes from you know what I
think the best thing for the creative
process is is keeping your mind sharp by
practicing staying present which I do by
listening to audiobooks on audible true
story I'm listening to one right now
called sapiens a brief history of
mankind and it's so fascinating to learn
about like how there are all different
species of humans and now we're down to
just one but I'll tell you sometimes I
have trouble like staying present and I
gotta hit the back 10 seconds button
which I do and that's when I know oh
yeah I think it's just good practice for
my mind and I'm so grateful to audible
for being the second sponsor to get
behind this podcast before it even came
out so everybody listening please show
some love to audible and they have shown
some love to you because if you go to
audible.com slash Stevo you can start
your 30-day trial another way is to text
steve-o to 500 500 to get into your
30-day trial and let's get back to Tony
Hawk so the Oscars was a big one but and
and when you said you pointed to the
2000s as like you're kind of like heavy
celebrity time to me that that seemed
kind of odd because for me it would be
like well of course the 80s and yeah the
eighties well okay so in the course of
skating skating got popular in the
eighties for sure but it was still very
much considered a novelty and sharp
they're obviously we as skaters who grew
up there thought it was everything but
like it was never on the news you know
what I mean it was never right it was
never in Main Street it was rarely in
commercials and stuff like that
what it was and and I think that this
this would probably be pretty accurate
is that nobody knew about it at all and
then 1985 Back to the Future yes about
and every kid in the world got a
skateboard for Christmas that year yep
in 1985 and like 98% of those kids found
out very quickly how difficult
skateboarding is you know it's like wait
a second this isn't fun I like this is
hard and like I fell down and I didn't
like that that hurts you know and so
it's a very small percentage of the kids
who get a skateboard that actually go on
to become in any way proficient and that
whole process serves to totally weed out
any kids that are like just half-ass you
know you have really isolated with
skateboarding like the most driven
persistent like like willing to
sacrifice like you know like go to any
lengths it's a pretty special person who
is a skateboarder and like at this time
that we're talking about it wasn't cool
you know yeah so you you choose to skate
and then it's hard yeah so everyone's
telling you to not do it or telling you
can't do it right parents are telling
you no I mean it was just you had to
really persevere it even just to do it
for fun at all not to be serious about
it but fast forward to so I think you're
right like Back to the Future was
definitely a catalyst for people to
start skating the next sort of wave of
that was I believe our video game series
because it there are a bunch of pros
these days that started skating because
they played it on a video game
yeah and yeah that's odd to me but I
believe it that's not your era right um
but I mean I'm talking about like some
of the best friends in the world
a guy like Shane O'Neill he played our
video game series and thought all that
stuff's possible possible this is the
guy who wins the battle at The Berrics
like routinely yeah yeah you could jump
from the top of the Venice high school
and do a grind on the rail for 25
seconds he's like yeah that's easy you
could do that yeah yeah and there well
there's some stunt skater dudes that
that's crazy they do yeah now that with
the history of skateboarding this is
another thing and I just I feel so
honored like it when I look at like the
the time that I've lived in you know
like I saw like the internet you know
like me like there's the amount of you
know technological advancement in our
lifetime it's really striking but to me
what's most it what's what honors me the
most is to have been alive for the birth
of Street skating you know yeah because
it wouldn't you started skateboarding I
have a different perspective on that but
yeah weightily because when you started
Street skating it was all about skate
parks halfpipes
but it was also because I was I was
professional vert skater right Street
skating became a thing onto itself well
right and then that became really the
the chosen way to skate because who
could find a vert ramp over here like I
just learned very all McTwist is that
cool still right I mean it was like
skateboarding was there there was no
such thing as Street skating you know it
like in the beginning of the 80s and and
then it what also happened in the 80s
was America became very litigious you
know all the sudden lawsuits were like
you know someone gets coffee spilled at
McDonald's it's a millions of dollars
lawsuit of all the skate parks closed so
all the skate parks closed because
nobody wanted to get sued nobody wanted
to have ramps because it was like
everybody's got lawsuits on their mind
all the parks closed down all the ramps
get torn down and skaters just flood out
onto the streets and then next thing you
know nobody wanted to see vert ramps
nobody cared about it and like Tony Hawk
here 20 for me here but yeah that was
when Street skating really came into its
own and I'm you know we're to say like
animal chin like was the seed
and then public domain boom it was it
was yep
so that was like 1988 yep and in and so
you know 1988 I was in eighth grade like
that's like right when I was like
bullied headlong into it and I was never
that good at skateboarding but like with
Street skating because it was in its
infancy I was like almost like kind of
like advancing with like the you know
like the yeah that put the general
progression of it right so and and you
being a vert skater and I could say this
you know probably about it and like you
know a handful of vert skaters like you
know I was sort of we were at the same
level of the low for sure so now this is
where it gets embarrassing for me
because fast-forward all these years and
I'm out of control on drugs
I mean lost my mind and and I'm
broadcasting my downward spiral to a
like a list of like 200 people
oh yeah briefly here's here's the thing
is that I had it was the most
influential people who like had the
misfortune of me getting ahold of their
contact info all on one email list like
the mall all cc'd you could see the
whole list and at one point at one point
after the what I called the rat email
list started I I got an email Knoxville
made the mistake of sending a mass email
list with everybody on copy you could
see everyone a copy so I just copied and
pasted like his Knoxville's entire
emails and then added it to my my rat
email is so now then I got full that now
Tony Hawk has landed on my rad email is
because he was in Knoxville's you know
like sorry so now I don't know Tony
Hawk's getting this like or like a daily
rap which is awful and her like I'm
steve-o's mad at somebody's growing off
or like steve-o's discovered a new
dimension you know like it was really
really gnarly stuff and a lot of people
were glued to it because there was just
such a train wreck but Tony being the
good guy that he is wasn't interested no
wasn't
he said the rat email list has become
full I can't add anyone else so if
anyone wants out let me know
like I'm out I said I I'm out because I
don't have time to read all of them I
was trying to be pragmatic is positive
how long were they I was just some yeah
some it might have been a video it might
have been an essay I mean they exist
somewhere yeah so basically I just like
I think I I don't have a good guy he's
like you know I like I'm good like you
know this doesn't make me feel what you
wish for right and then answer now now I
received this from from Tony Hawk and
I'm just like what huh and I'm like so I
start with everybody and I'm copy I
start attacking Tony I started tagging
with everybody like the whole thing and
I'm like you like you were never even
that rad you were never even that red I
ripped over you at Street skating we're
having coffee like right sure yeah but
let the record reflect that now that I
have like painstakingly gone through the
last 30 years of footage of me skating
and like I was not even close to anybody
can can see this because now I've got my
untold story of steve-o skateboard video
career you can you know you can what is
that wall right thing up now it's not up
yet by the time this comes out it will
be the untold story of steve-o
skateboard career and don't let the word
maybe that was our reckoning was the
wall ride right I did the wall ride
frontside like six times
warming up waiting for you to do it I
know that I've said this in the past but
let me just say to you know for the
public record like that was like the
most embarrassing thing for me for you
to have forgiven me and gone on to be
such a good guy such a such a dear
friend and and always you know generous
with your time whenever I've got some
dumb idea like this one I just want to
say I'm sorry for that and thank you oh
it was it was a they say it's a good
story did you got into there I'm sure
there are a lot of background
conversations happening in those email
that he wasn't no because I was just
like email me about something else I did
the wrap-up show on time and I he was
like hey man were you on that steve-o
loose I'm like yes and then I said I had
I had to get out and he's like you could
just feel the drugs in the emails what
year was this and then the first few
months of 2008 and then I got sober and
then when did you guys ever run into
each other right after that like I
remember Tony reached out to me to do
his Sirius XM radio show and were you
like and I was like oh my god like I
can't I can't even believe it Tony
actually wants like have something to do
with me like I was like in Barry I think
and that like for him to reach out like
and and I was just there was so much so
much healing in that you know did you do
it the show like I remembered it but it
was just it was just such a mess that's
so it was just like okay like he was
just so you know sober at that point
right yeah I've been sober ever since
the rat email is and and I
could even say pretty definitively that
I've been sober ever since because of
the ratty melon I mean dude like like
this whole period what was it was just
such a it was such a cry for help yeah
in in disguise where everyone's reading
a gun what we got to do something here
yeah can't go on I mean you didn't
schedule like you're like I did the man
like I'm gonna if I can jump out the
window the window not so said okay we'll
be there
great the best part about all of that is
well when they did the show about your
the intervention but the best part of
all that is that you [ __ ] filmed
everything wasted no one has all that
documentation and you've never seen that
no I I end up watching it I mean I've
never wanted to watch it I ended up
watch oh the whole show you I've watched
that yeah there were two things I wasn't
gonna watch which was the DVD I made
called PCP saved my life you've ever
seen that I did I watched that and and
it was every bit as bad as I thought and
then there and then there was the demise
and rise thing which one did you hate
more or watching which one did I hate
more watching uh oh god they're equally
it's awful it's super embarrassing you
feel like it was like healing to see you
yeah or some people would think that to
watch footage that's like so
embarrassing would would humble you make
you think oh I never want to be like
that again yeah but I know I know I
never want to be like that again
my experience at watching the footage is
that like oddly like when I watched the
Amy Winehouse documentary I walked out I
was like man god I wanna get high it's
triggering somehow like I see the drugs
on camera it's like I could taste them
you know I brought back like this inside
just don't want any part of watching
that I remember around that time around
those same years especially with Jack I
said why do I have to be steve-o but
there was a time when I saw you I want
to say it at Universal
it was like nine snails or something and
it was like a DVD release party and and
something like that no no no I'm talking
about before that it was some concert I
remember it was it was a concert you and
I ended up as like a rock or something
and we I saw you in the stairwell going
like going up to the from the backstage
up to the seats or something like that
and there's all these people around like
Stevo and so he feels like he has to do
something so then he does a handstand
and walks down the stairs because he's
on display like and and I just remember
thinking like does he have to do it all
the time does he always have to that's
the beauty of being you know in your 20s
and 30s man like on drugs like no matter
how loaded I could pop up in a handstand
and go walking downstairs on my hands no
it was impressive and but also I and I
wasn't of the mindset where I was like
what's wrong with him I was like oh yeah
there's Steve oh yeah high five Tony's
perspective oh man like how sad that he
feels I guess to do that all the time it
wasn't it wasn't even maybe it was
because it was also in the height of
Jackass success so if that was like at
the end of Jackass success or ever is
one then then it would feel sad but did
you recognize that because like you did
you ever feel like that when you started
getting famous like you had to be like
on all the time or just was skating for
sure was skating it's hard for me to
just walk to a skate park now because
it's like kids just sit down like oh
let's see some magic I'm like dude first
of all never been here super old yeah
where is your vert ramp right so it's
like that for you in the beginning like
when you show up to a skate park like
all right [ __ ] it I would start busting
things out yeah and it was it was what
was easier for me to I was more
adaptable and I was younger and so so
back then but but I always I always put
that sort of unspoken pressure on myself
to yeah maybe to a fault that's what I
was because because people would people
would be like what is he trying to outdo
us you know like other skaters
especially of
my peers they're just like - do you
always have to like can't we just yeah
that's a big realization to realize
about yourself there's a lot to this
right here because like I mean for me
that what Tony's talking about where I
feel like I always had to do something
like I was never I didn't have an off
switch at all and that's like a pretty
sad like you know thing if that's how
you're always gonna be like for me to
have any hope of aging at all gracefully
or just at least not tragically I had to
find some separation between Stevo and
like whoever I really am in my personal
would you realize that that was like
with sobriety you know like a year or
two in or like right away if you can't
turn it off and if you identify as like
this persona that you've created for the
masses then you're [ __ ]
yeah pleasing yourself to death right
and so like it's an interesting thing
because I used to look at like Tommy Lee
who I think it's 12 years older than me
and when every time I saw Tommy Lee's
still partying I thought I got 10 more
years my 10-year bond my ten-year buffer
zone I always made me feel better and
then in sobriety like I looked at Tony
Hawk you know and I think Tony's only
like 7 years older than I am
but but that's him did it when you're
like someone who's physical you know
like as a career and like getting old is
really scarier and and like I want to
say that dude to see you do the 50
tricks at 50 years old like - you did a
900 like when you're like 448 yes no 100
I mean like - just it's there's a new
standard for physicality at the age of
50 which we can thank Tony Hawk for like
but I think that I really do believe
that just wanting to perform and wanting
to skate well still into my older age is
what kept me on the straight and narrow
because I saw pretty quickly especially
my 40s that if I was out drinking like I
never went you know so far like blackout
drunk but if I was drinking kind of
consistently
i I couldn't skate for more than a half
hour right next day and then I was like
I keep if I want to keep skating that's
got to end right that's kind of where it
landed me so for us to like you know
look at you and see you see longevity
which like what's your diet like do
stretch everyday if you workout I'm
pretty bad at all that oh I've never
been one to stretch a really warm up and
stuff like that just didn't really work
for me God that goes but but I think it
was just more just being more being more
cognizant of what I am eating and what I
it it was subtle and and changed more as
I got older but it was just more like
not doing everything to excess not
getting to excess not snacking not
partying and at some point you realize
that oh it you know things can be calm
and you can still be effective and
successful and it's great I learned it
pretty late too though I did like I
didn't learn as I was really on my 40s
because somehow I was just under the
under the impression that I can do this
like I can bring Caleb both ends still
do 900 I'm good damn it's so crazy hey
sorry to interrupt your thumb are you
still on those sugar yeah how long has
it been
October 13th is my sobriety date for
compulsive eaters Anonymous like any
sugar in its natural state now here
let's let's wrap this up and I just like
this this idea of like you know midlife
crisis kind of thing I want to say that
like again that looking to you you're my
seven year buffer zone Kevin's table was
mine but he's only two years old right
so when I see Kevin skate I'm like I got
two more years yeah I'm a DI I love it I
love it and Scott here once said that I
he heard that the first third of your
life is for making mistakes make it as
many mistakes as you can
the second third of your life is for
making as much money as you can yeah and
the third third of your life even away
as much money as you can
yeah and foundations are okay and that
resonated with me and I think that I
think that Tony is an example of that
because we you know we look at I mean
except for the mistakes part a lot of
merging them into those errors for me
but I think that not just giving your
money but really more giving your your
time and your support that you know not
just money but I think that I've learned
that that I can be effective just by
being there yeah or just by raising
awareness or raising a voice or writing
a hand I mean everything that you're
doing with building the skate parks at
the Tony Hart Foundation I think that my
Tony Hawk foundation signed board is in
the van right here somewhere
oh yeah I think so that's a dead loved
it at what point were you like I want to
have a foundation give back like was
that pretty early on or that was around
the 2000 mm because now it wasn't a PR
move is more because I started going to
skate park there were all these key
parts cropping up and mostly in affluent
areas and I would get invited to these
grand openings we got a skate park in
this you know in this town and is
obviously like mostly rich white
suburban yeah us and their parks sucked
and I was like what is wrong here you
spent all this money on this thing and
it's worse than the parking lot at the
mall yeah when people who don't skate
yeah exactly
it looked like they were trying to copy
the game 720 right and so I thought I
can probably help here somehow I didn't
know how and that was it I just like I
want to start a skate park Foundation
and try to guide not only the the
construction in a better way but the
funding and where that's where it goes
because there's all kinds of kids in
low-income areas that want to skate and
then I'm anything yeah and they found
skating and they have found an outlet
and they're basically told you can't do
that because there's nowhere to do it
right so that was the that was the
catalyst that was the
yeah and keep in mind that that Tony
Hawk pro skater like just said all kinds
of records and in the video game space
for sure yeah I definitely had a lot of
resources I had a lot of I had a lot of
connections it's just so rad too so
there's the Tony Hawk foundation
building building skate parks and I see
you doing all kinds of stuff to fight
Alzheimer's and help you know but it's
just you just kind of I stay with what I
know and what I experience and having a
skate park I mean I got lucky del Marske
branch was one of the only parks in the
US Open and that was my home away from
home that's where I found my crew that's
where I found my style sense of musics
you know everything and so I just want
that same opportunity for kids who just
love skating and not because I'm we're
trying to make breeding grounds or
training facilities just so they have a
place to belong that's great how's that
the one kid the kid from from Africa
they had the documentary talent yeah
he's know pretty good he is doing skate
lessons he moved to not Johannesburg
what's the Cape Town he moved to Cape
Town and does skate lessons so yeah all
right yeah why hey man we gotta get you
out of here and I just want to tell you
again thank you man this was uh it sucks
it got so hot in here but I noticed the
heat that's right we're talking about
that before yeah but you're just so
generous with your time and indeed what
an example you are in every way man I
appreciate it
hey I think that you are such a great
voice for sobriety things I mean like if
I could ever point to anyone it's like
hey look at Stevo look where he what
could be what he accomplished look what
he went through and look where he is now
and you can do it you know I mean like
you from the rat emails
that's crazy
and I'm really grateful for you Tony
thank you so much and I'll really be
mindful to try not to ask you for any
favors for a good no I love it all right
thank you
ah dude if you're still listening please
shoot a tweet to me on Twitter because I
just want to know if people just are
into this man I'm super psyched totally
grateful to all of you to Scott Randolph
to Tony Hawk this was our first episode
like I said it was a long time coming
there's many more to follow and they're
gonna be better and better and better I
know it so make sure you're subscribed
to this wild ride with steve-o podcast
at Apple podcasts if you're on youtube
leave a comment in the comment section
make sure you're subscribed to this
podcast channel and dude I'm just really
excited so thank all of you thanks to
the sponsors thanks to El Chapo turn it
on yourself John but watch out for that
whiteboard
tell your friends you were coming out
hard yeah really really psyched man and
thank you I know there's a lot of
podcasts out there but thank you guys
for supporting this one yeah dude